Saudi Arabia the heart of the Middle
East Sally has an incredible history an
immersive culture and Saudi hospitality
is legendary today Saudi is also known
as the world's largest oil exporter and
it's also home to the world's largest
green hydrogen project and now home to
the world's first cognitive City Saudi
Arabia is headed towards a new Direction
a new tomorrow a new future that's
powered by technology
in the digital Kingdom I will tell the
story of Saudi Arabia's vision of
entering a new age the age of a
technology driven future from the
world's largest Smart City developments
to changing the focus of government to
utilize data to drive the economy the
Saudi economic landscape is rapidly
shifting towards technology and
Innovation and what is apparent is with
its incredible talent pool future
opportunities and focus on technology
are together going to create a new join
me Ian Khan in my journey of finding out
what the future holds for Saudi Arabia
as I speak with leading experts in
government the private sector global
technology companies and others to learn
about the evolution of the digital
Kingdom
foreign
has a strategy to make the kingdom the
hub for AI development and AI in general
by the year 2030. some of the
organizations that are responsible for
making this happen are Sadaya the Saudi
data and artificial intelligence agency
that was formed just a few years ago but
over the last couple of years it has
made incredible progress by launching
different apps especially through the
pandemic there's a focus to use
technology such as artificial
intelligence and of course Cloud
Technologies and others to make sure
this data is utilized to the best extent
to help everyday common people to
utilize technology and to benefit today
is an ecosystem this is not just one
single entity so we do have the ndmo the
national data management office
which is the entity that is responsible
of setting the policies drafting the
laws that are related to data and AI to
make sure that we are from the
legislative perspective we are mature
enough for the economy to be developed
also there is the national Center of
artificial intelligence which is the
entity that is responsible of doing the
r d in data and Ai and developing
innovative solutions to contribute to
the economy and take it to the next
level and we have in ic the national
information center which is the entity
that's responsible of developing and
operating Mega data and AI initiatives
that would enable the sector and Sadaya
is the entity that is orchestrating all
of the efforts in a way that we make
sure that we are advancing properly
towards our national admissions in data
and AI data actually is the new oil
countries now are recognizing the impact
of data and it becomes actually as a
National Asset for them through
maximizing the data collection and
processing and also generating valuable
solutions from the data that data
massive data that allowed us to see a
things from not just 10 000 feet but
from 100
000 feet we can do all the data Fusion
that is possible to be done you have the
Education data you have a labor market
data you have commercial registration
data so then you can do all the data
Fusion help decision makers to get from
basic aggregations all the way to
building machine learning models that
can answer sophisticated questions all
the way to building simulations to
simulate certain policies the
Investments that the kingdom has put in
place when it comes to the digitization
of the kingdom in the past 10 15 years
is paying off now
a lot of people were questioning whether
those Investments back then were the
right investment and the kingdom even
doubled down
on those Investments five six years ago
in Vision 2030 was established we were
going even bigger in today's
fast-changing world the demands for data
governance data management and
information management in general are
some of the biggest challenges for both
the private as well as the public sector
for governments especially the ability
to efficiently manage citizen data and
citizen information is of the highest
importance and to achieve this
technology provides a number of avenues
we see use cases from many different
countries across the world where huge
progress has been made by using
cutting-edge Technologies to manage user
data in fact a number of governments
across the world have started using
decentralized databases such as
blockchain to manage citizen data Saudi
Arabia is leading its efforts to ensure
citizen data is safe and more than
anything else that the highest level of
privacy and data protection are enabled
for any information that is gathered
from citizens this is the core of the
Saudi digital identity program nafat
one domain that you are extremely proud
to be working at is the digital identity
we have developed Nevada it's a single
sign-on solution so for an individual
user a digital user he has one
credential that he could use to access
multiple applications what do you get by
doing that first you make the journey
extremely Pleasant and then for the
applications they don't really have to
incur additional costs because they
really don't have to keep and maintain
identity access Management Solutions now
we have more than 17 million users
subscribing to our service
and we have about more than 360 is all
subscribing to ourselves so for those 17
million users they can access about more
than 300 applications using the same
credentials all government entities plus
the private sector are deeply committed
create the digitization journey build
the infrastructure there are multiple
layers in this so Nic Sadaya is actually
touching across all these layers
starting from the digital infrastructure
that enables innovators by which we can
monetize this data and benefit out of
this data create all these kind of
innovative experiences this means we
need to focus on data quality if this
data is not a good equality or not
achieve the goal at the end in addition
to that SME is an entrepreneurs are not
only looking for open data but we should
focus on other mechanism that helps
support and to get high quality data and
utilize this data to come up with some
products or services that help support
society as a hub data undoubtedly plays
a critical role in everything that
happens in our world today even traffic
lights and Roads generate data and the
progress that Saudi Arabia has made and
continues make in this domain is
extremely impressive Saudi also handles
a very critical part of a massive amount
of data management in a short duration
of time in the year and that is during
the Journey of Hajj the Islamic
pilgrimage that takes place every year
in Saudi Arabia over 20 million Muslims
from across the world come to Mecca and
managing data and information and that
volume and veracity is a task in its own
this is just one example of how
seriously Saudi Arabia is taking
information and data management and the
whole idea of digital identity very
seriously
[Music]
foreign
2019 and 2021 the covid-19 pandemic
stuck the whole world it crippled entire
countries every industry across the
world was shocked by the disruption in
business and billions of dollars across
the world were incurred in losses
Nations did what they could to contain
the breakout and keep their citizens
safe one key challenge in this time was
the delivery of new government services
and for that it was necessary to lay
down the foundations for new processes
and systems this is where Saudi Arabia
excelled by developing a new solution
tavakalna
literally translating to trust the
release of tawakalna was one of the
fastest deployments of a
technology-based solution for a country
of almost 35 million people when to
Ocala started it was actually initially
just for permission
so people used to apply to ask for
permits for them to move from one place
to another but then over time as the
pandemic gets deeper and deeper there
was a need
to create a system
that allows everyone in the country to
check the immunity and the start of the
health status of people and we started
building the team started building all
these services to enable all the law
enforcement all the Facility Owners shop
owners to check whether this person got
Corona or not this was the first service
that
suddenly became required Sadaya was able
to pull all resources around with
national Information Center building on
the infrastructure building over
development team creating all the
journeys the team were literally on
Sleepless weeks and not nights for
almost
two months or so they need to create
these services in very short period of
time and without jeopardizing security
the algebraidizing Privacy without
jeopardizing performance and the amount
of support we got from from the top
leadership of the country was tremendous
Saudi is not new to collaboration in
fact it was the vision of modern Saudi
Arabia's founder King Abdul Aziz al-saud
who laid the foundation of Saudi
Arabia's economy to collaboration the
partnership with foreign oil companies
led to not only the development of the
oil industry but also to its
skyrocketing growth to the extent that
Saudi Arabia has become one of the
world's largest exporters of oil in the
last eight decades the kingdom continues
the tradition of collaboration and
leading many new initiatives this
includes laying down the foundations of
initiatives such as the digital
cooperation an organization a think tank
dedicated to helping countries across
the world take a step into digital
transformation or the establishment of
the future investment Institute a think
tank that was founded in Saudi and now
is a global Organization for investing
into the future Saudi is now home to new
initiatives in the areas of carbon
exchange manufacturing agritech
technology climate change and more
much of this is attributed to the
initiative known as Vision 2030. When I
visit countries that have great ambition
I often ask them are you positioning
yourself
not to be good at what you're doing
which you can be but to lead others to
create models for other communities in
other countries this nation has decided
that they want to be Innovation leaders
that they want to be able to create new
ideas and new solutions that solve
problems in the United States or around
this region or into Africa and it's
clear to me looking around that if the
existing trajectory
continues this will be a formidable
Force globally
in just a few years if you read the
vision 2030 you will find a lot of
things to be achieved on the logistics
side on the tourism side Healthcare
education and you name it in order for
the government to be able to achieve
them you have to have a digital strong
robust digital Foundation behind it
listen we cannot build enough data
centers quick enough okay the the
transformation is massive the form we
built here is in partnership with the
company called nadek a national
agriculture development company a
traditional Dairy and juices another
company that is really trying to
innovate and and Tech up if you will and
join the new economy right what's great
is we saw nadek investing in a 30
megawatt solar power Farm well what we
did is partnered on their land we're
building inside of what used to be
Alfalfa crop pivots wasting a lot of
water but they have the water
infrastructure and now we have a huge
scale farm that'll be producing 140 tons
a week of Premium Tomatoes starting in
March 140 tons a week 6 significant
capacity of 16 varieties of tomatoes
half of which have never been tried in
the region they're novel products where
we're changing The Human Experience in
the in the platter but also at a much
lower cost than Imports very little
water consumption right and it's all
made possible by two partners coming
together a traditional company with
infrastructure and US partnering with
that infrastructure with our our
capabilities when it comes to
collaborators definitely we get to
collaborate with the leading companies
in the data artificial intelligence but
yes I think you need to be extremely
selective in what could offer you a
better solution this is very important
and when it comes to benchmarking
usually when we get to develop our
strategies whether their business
strategies
it's a strategy we really work with
their best leading consulting firms to
make sure that we get to Benchmark
ourselves and to properly sit our
Ambitions and our goals and to do to
start from where others ended not from
where others started and our vision is
to establish the kingdom as a global
leader and the elite lead of the data
and AI driven economy so here in Riyadh
digital City we have all the government
entities all the offices and what you
see here is a different kind of energy
when it comes to collaboration when it
comes to meeting people everything is
around here so it's been incredible
meeting different people from different
government entities and talking to them
about the actual change that is
happening here in Saudi Arabia
[Music]
I'm here at the Region's largest
technology conference something that
hasn't happened in the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia for many years in fact this
conference called leap is the first of
many of these initiatives that are going
to take place at this conference we're
hearing about trillions of dollars of
investment money into different
initiatives for example technology spent
on artificial intelligence blockchain
connected cars infrastructure
development and many other things Saudi
Arabia is at a critical point right now
because it's focusing more on the data
economy rather than what it's been doing
for the past eight ten decades is
focused on oil the future of the Saudi
Market is more about leveraging
technology to change everything to
change the economy to change jobs to
empower Youth and communities to build a
new kingdom that powers not just itself
but the entire Middle East right from
the beginning of the different
industrial revolutions automation has
been a key factor for Progress today
automation acts as an accelerator for
most Industries operating in any country
Industrial Automation is highly used in
Saudi Arabia due to its focus on
Industries such as the energy industry
and its various aspects such as upstream
and downstream oil refining
petrochemicals electricity generation
and Manufacturing Industries what is the
future of Automation in saudi's fast
developing economy this also opens up
the discussion for a thriving cyber
security industry in Saudi Arabia the
first step we do in digitalization is
where we move into we can automate and
connect something it's cheap we automate
everything which is non-core everything
which is core
that means you differentiate on we don't
touch you can come closer to your
clients you can have a more
um view from your end-to-end Supply
Chain management information right you
can have a direct view on where the
product is on your Warehouse you can
manage and control far better these are
important tools for oil and gas these
are important tools for government
sectors to provide better services and
all of this the next step we move into
is that you are the owner of that
information
think about in two three years
I think in Saudi you will hold
your own health care record
you will have your information on your
taxes on your services on your cars
everything in one that is totally locked
and cyber secure see I think that we
need to rework at is the end user
awareness because regardless how much
Investments you have done in protecting
the infrastructure and the digital
assets if you have a user with not much
awareness he could be the loophole and
many attacks
come through the end users not through
the infrastructure and the protected
infrastructure in today's fast-growing
Saudi economy there are multiple
hundreds of billions of dollars of
investment being put into infrastructure
upskilling talent digitalization and
other critical aspects of making Saudi a
global economic leader today the kingdom
has multiple Venture funds that are
creating hundreds of startups and
solving some of the biggest problems in
the world the Saudis of putting their
money where their mouth is you've got
billions of dollars of investment fund
going into entrepreneurship accelerators
and incubators you've got Giga projects
happening we're talking about neon which
has to be one of the biggest projects or
construction projects in the world the
history of the world 500 billion dollar
financed City and area of the future so
clearly the time is right to bring the
world's most emerging Technologies
futurists impactful people working in
Tech to Saudi Arabia so that they can be
part of this journey and feed into it
one element we see here they Embrace
digitalization like this is a normal
part of their Gene right it just turns
on something for them they're even
excited about it so everything is
connected everything is somehow sensed
the early evolution of smart cities is
now turning on the development of
cognitive cities Urban Development is
fast changing the way we live study work
and travel Saudi today has embarked on
multiple Mega infrastructure projects
such as neon the line Red Sea
development and others we are a planet
now that where over half of humanity
lives in cities and that's just going to
grow over the next few years this is
going to be the century of cities and
all the big issues whether it's
Transportation or energy or the climate
emergency we've got to solve these
within cities because this is not just a
topic about our Urban centers this is a
topic about the future of the planet so
faced with some great challenges and all
they promise that cities bring we've got
to bring new innovation new ideas new
technologies to apply against these big
problems and you know while we can do
the right thing we ought to do good we
can also do well we can build businesses
we can build new innovation that creates
new solutions for communities all over
the world like at the end of the day
smart cities is about quality of life
it's about better Human Experience for
everybody
a huge majority of Saudis are youth with
approximately 37 percent under the age
of 14. 51 of the Kingdom's population is
under the age of 25 with such an
incredible talent pool of future
generation economic contributors Saudi
is sitting on a resource that many
nations are currently struggling with
the kingdom is home to institutes such
as the King Abdullah University of
Science and Technology and King Fahad
University of petroleum and minerals to
name a few some of the world's top
talent is now teaching faculty at these
institutions and the quality of learning
and gaining skills To Build A Better
Tomorrow are second to none Saudi is
truly undergoing a new technology and
education Revolution it's very
interesting time in Saudi Arabia with
vision 2030 and all of the digital
initiatives that's happening there is a
lot of investment in terms of balance
and job creation for the skills of the
future mciit the ministry of information
and telecommunication is investing a lot
in in a huge initiative that targets the
skills of the future for Saudi local
health and for the citizens what we are
doing at Microsoft as well part of that
direction is we have managed to train
more than 100
000 students in iot AI cloud computing
and others we're also working very
closely with the governments and
organizations to also train and simulate
the work of technical people so
definitely data and AI offered many
opportunities and by the way the
opportunities are not only technical
that is also the opportunities related
to governance and policies by enhancing
the maturity of the legislative maturity
the data and artificial intelligence you
will open more opportunities for people
to work in this field
like having Liars indicate artificial
intelligence having legal expert in data
artificial intelligence policy experts
are we doing really a good job when it
comes to building those universities
choosing the disciplines that your those
University should focus on how can we
make sure that those universities the
output of those universities very much
aligned with with the labor market needs
and so the idea is that we work with the
Ministry of Education we work with the
ministry of human resources and Social
Services to do such evaluation and the
results were you know very surprising to
many we enable those universities to to
use such insights to help them make
better decisions when it comes to the
Investments that they will make one of
the characteristics
of this great nation of the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia right now is that it has a
very large and growing young population
and
they have a chance
to create a new future to bring new
ideas to the table they need to create
and be engaged in the type of future
that they want so that means expanding
education to include things like
software development programming like
we're seeing all over the world this is
already happening of course giving as
many children as possible access to the
different tools that could enable them
to be inspired to understand things like
science technology engineering
mathematics applied to solve the great
problems of a great nation countries
want to create environments where
the young population and the new working
population don't feel like they have to
look elsewhere for the great
opportunities that they are here at home
and that means investing in our kids
investing in their education
inspiring them and really believing what
they can do to create a a prosperous
future for this land I'm quite used to
going to Tech events in different
countries and one of the most arresting
things about Saudi is the fact that you
have such a large proportion of female
visitors to this event and the tech
industry in Saudi Arabia has 28 female
participation at this moment in time and
that is an upwards Trend and it's
growing that is leading World leading in
terms of other countries
[Music]
Saudi today is headed towards the future
with no stops perhaps the next few years
will be a revelation for the rest of the
world as Saudi doubles down on its
technology Investments its focus on
developing its talent pool and
potentially becoming a Powerhouse of
different Industries and a hub in the
Middle East all of the sectors that we
are working at be it held beat energy
can be definitely affected by data and
artificial intelligence even the
renewable energy
in fact
we are working now on the energy and the
health sector trying to use data and AI
techniques to advance those sectors
so we believe that data and AI could be
key to many of our challenges I can say
openly Saudi is serious about this they
have realized the need for economic
diversification and for having the Saudi
people participate both in the value
creation and the value capture of
technology and to improve the lives of
you know Saudi consumers Saudi Market
participants Etc so people will see you
know the transformation and the economic
growth of Saudi as a very real thing it
will entice them to commit to the region
and to commit to the country as we have
we're actively here our largest asset
anywhere is built here because we
acknowledge the size of the market we
see the opportunity we found like-minded
Partners like in nadek and nodex partly
owned by the public investment fund
right all the way up to the leadership
here there you really see an appetite
for change and I think that excites
people like me and entrepreneurs who
want to make an impact and want to build
something exciting the Middle East is
the New Year particularly when looking
at the demographics of this gym and
there's almost 500 million
young people in the Middle East you know
people under the age of 30. the promise
and potential around this region is
enormous and serious amounts of
investment into getting this youth into
technical jobs stem jobs into technology
so I think you're going to see a hub
programming you know a hub for cyber
security Excellence a hub for gaming and
you know software engineering it's very
exciting and it's definitely a place of
growth Saudi Arabia is creating the
largest Esports arena in the world right
now I see Saudi Arabia becoming the next
big hub for Esports it will be the
future for gaming we're the biggest
economy in the Middle East we are the
largest oil transporter in the world so
we do have a big responsibility we are
also the Islamic destination for a big
Muslim Nation a lot of responsibility on
Saudi Arabia and I think we are standing
up to this responsibility and continue
to drive this change in the region will
continue to be the backbone of the
Middle East
[Music]
the future is ever so Elusive and
unpredictable but very much available to
us in plain sight if we choose to look
at the right signals
the world today is at a Crossroads
between fighting disease that transcends
Nations Wars that are crippling the
global economy and unpredictable
financial and other events that impact
not just one country but everyone across
the world Saudi Arabia is moving fast
towards a new vision Vision 2030 and has
invested significantly in its
infrastructure and Technology the next
few years are going to be the beginning
of a new era the era of the digital
Kingdom my journey as a filmmaker takes
me to places where the story is not
breaking but where breakthroughs are
happening and where massive changes are
happening in the future the digital
Kingdom has been made possible by the
trust and help of a lot of people and we
thank everyone who was part of this
journey a big thanks to Informer Michael
Champion Annabelle Mander and the team
that hosted us at leap I'd also like to
thank the leadership team at Sadaya who
were extremely generous with their time
with us and everyone who took the time
to interview with us and lastly those
who believe that Saudi Arabia is an
incredible place to be